JENNIFER DANIEL: Hi.
My name's Jennifer Daniel.
I'm the Expressions
Creative Director,
and I'm going to talk to you
about how we encode gender
into technical
artifacts, such as emoji.
Working on Google's
emoji program
has a large breadth of
interesting aspects of my job.
It includes reviewing emoji
proposals, designing emojis,
and the experience using them.
It means working with teams all
across Google, like the Fonts
team to innovate on the font
technology, or with Gboard
to improve search
prediction and suggestion.
If you're running the latest
software on your phone,
there's over 3,000 emojis.
And each one of those goes
through a rigorous process
to really land on your keyboard.
I want to talk quickly
about one proposal that
came across our desk, not too
long ago, for a knot emoji.
Ta-da!
Knot.
A knot emoji.
OK, sure.
When reviewing proposal,
a large part of my job
is to anticipate,
is this something
that people are already using
that warrants emojification?
Is this something that
will be frequently used?
And the proposal talks
about some fairly reasonable
examples, like people
tie knots when they sail.
The knot is an
often used metaphor
to talk about marriage,
like tying the knot.
However, what the
proposal doesn't get into
is how the knot has become
emblematic of other things.
For example, when paired with
an emoji, such as a tree,
it can communicate something
like lynching or suicide.
My job as a designer is to, not
just anticipate those problems,
but demonstrate how
design can truly change
the function of something.
Like creating a knot
that's more colorful
or a different
style of knot that
has less negative connotations.
My job in emoji didn't start
to long ago, maybe about 2018
or so.
And it didn't start
with this, but this
is when I really
started investigating
how we encode gender
into technical artifacts,
such as emoji.
And it was when I texted
a friend in a meeting.
Love a good mansplain,
woman face-palming.
And she, on her phone,
received love a good mansplain,
but with a man face-palming.
Now even though
both of these emojis
are technically the same since
they map to the same code
point, they were rendering
in different genders.
And this creates all kinds of
cross platform inconsistencies,
like--
"Oh, this is an image for
a person in steamy room.
What is that man doing there?
I do not need to see him.
I am alone.
I'm trying to be peaceful
in my steam room."
It turns out, this
happens a number of times.
I send you a merperson
from my Pixel device,
and you get a merman
on your iPhone.
You send me a dead
zombie on your iPhone,
and I get a dead lady
on my Android device.
So what's happening here?
Well, basically, vendors
such as Apple, and Facebook,
and Google, and Samsung,
have given gendered designs
for emojis that aren't supposed
to be explicitly gendered.
And this creates a number
of problems when there
aren't even inconsistencies.
For example,
construction worker,
which is not supposed
to be male or female,
everyone has designed
to be male, reinforcing
a stereotype unnecessarily.
Or police officer, not
policemen not police women,
again, everyone's
designed as male.
However, once you get to
the more emotional gestures,
they all default to female.
Person pouting, person
frowning, and person shrugging
are all women.
And this is deeply
annoying and stupid.
So how did we get here?
Well, first, you must understand
that emoji are part of Unicode.
What is Unicode?
They're a standards body that
encodes the world's languages.
Unicode, to put it
simply, says that here
are characters on a list.
This is what they mean.
This is what their names are.
And this is how they map
between legacy and codings
in a universal character set.
So Unicode has a subcommittee
to standardize these pictograms,
which I serve on.
And now, true to
emoji's name, emoji
are defined by two
attributes: the picture
the user sees on the
screen, and second,
the code that defines it.
And Unicode's job is to create
that code and those guidelines.
However, Unicode only
makes recommendations.
They don't actually decide
what the letters or punctuation
really looks like.
That's up to font designers.
And so now, we
have this cacophony
of different saxophones.
You look at Apple's design.
They tend to design their
emojis very, very realistically,
perhaps as a holdover from
the company's early days
in skeuomorphic design.
What's up emoji are effectively
cheap knockoffs of Apple's.
Microsoft embraces
a more flat design,
due to their font technology.
And Google's designs are
more cartoonish and squishy.
The moon emoji is probably
my favorite example
of how these different
design approaches can really
change the meaning of an emoji.
So this is the moon emoji.
It's a crescent moon.
Pretty self-explanatory.
But it's so much more than that.
LG has a septum piercing.
Facebook's looks like
a little bit of cheese.
Microsoft reminds me
of a rotten banana,
and Twitter's is a toenail.
Emoji design has
evolved quite a bit
from the '90s, when it
first became popular.
This shift in creating designs
to show off retina screens
has really left a critical
part of what made emojis
useful in the first place.
Emojis are no longer
letters and words.
The drink emoji is a
great example of it.
The original drink emoji was
just the idea of a drink.
But now, as designers
sort of fetishize
the design of what a
Martini looks like,
it is no longer a drink emoji.
It's a dirty Martini,
one olive, straight up.
It's a very, very
specific type of drink.
And when you get more
specific and more detailed,
it begs the question, well
now we have a Martini.
What about a glass of whiskey
or a tropical drink or a beer?
And over time sure
enough, we now
have a full bar available
in our keyboards.
This isn't a trivial
new direction for emoji.
When a design removes as
much detail as possible,
it effectively--
it conveys the idea
of it rather than
literally reproducing reality.
So just going to
have a brief moment
of silence for the
original gender
inclusive emoji, the blobs.
What are they?
I do not know.
Emojis really could have
gone in two directions.
In the early days, Android had
these little blob characters,
which are neither animal nor
human, ageless, and broad.
And Apple went into a direction
that was a lot more specific.
The original emoji were
simple and abstract
and gender and race were
reasonably obscured.
However, in the hands of
some designers in California,
these early design
decisions radically
changed the trajectory
for Unicode and emojis.
As emojis were designed with
more explicitly Caucasian
and gender
signifiers, we started
to see cracks in the system.
Despite Unicode guidelines
to remain neutral,
police officers
designed as a man,
and when five skin tone
variants were encoded,
Apple changed their default
from Caucasian to gold.
But gold is effectively
just another version
of a cartoon white character.
And so here we are now, 2020,
opting for more detail, instead
of less.
And that's how our
adorable emojis
evolved from the
concept of a kiss
to hetero-normative
representations of gender
and sexuality.
However, over the
past couple of years,
we've managed to
convince others to start
to un-sex these emojis.
What's particularly interesting
to me here, is Google
made this mistake.
And corrected it.
Then made the same mistake
again, and then tried
to correct it again.
It's just sometimes progress
is reversing legacy decisions.
So now, there's this
Unicode document.
It's known as-- it's
like [INAUDIBLE]..
It's sort of like
the emoji Bible,
and it provides guidance
to how to implement emoji.
Regarding gender, it states
other than the above list shown
here, human form
emoji should normally
be depicted in a
gender neutral way,
unless gender appearance
is explicitly specified.
And that's all fine
and good, until you
realize that as of Unicode
11.0, 63 of the 87 emoji
were defined as
gender inclusive.
But most vendors did
not have unique designs
for these glyphs.
These are the only 11 emoji
that everyone supports
in a gender ambiguous design.
Child, adult, older person,
snowboarder, angel, baby,
skier, person in bad, fencer,
person in bathtub, and horse
racer.
So let's take a look at
these guys for a second.
Most of these emojis are
unique, in that they blissfully
exist without male
or female partners.
Meaning there's no baby girl
angel or man in bathtub.
It's just person in
bathtub and just angel.
However, there are three
child, adult, an older person,
that do have male
and female partners.
And this is really interesting,
because it indicates
that people are
trying to operate
within a spectrum of gender,
rather than subscribing
to a false binary.
And that makes me optimistic.
However, as of emoji
12.0 the only designs
that Apple supported
were for those 11
previously mentioned emoji.
All the other emoji that was
supposed to be gender inclusive
were not.
This was true of Microsoft.
This was true of Facebook.
This was true of Twitter.
Samsung inexplicitly has also
supported gender inclusive
superhero and super villain.
I don't quite know
why, but I suspect
it's because most
of their features
were heavily obscured,
which made making
the design a little bit easier.
Like a baby step.
Google wasn't too
far off either.
Google did not
support most of these.
And it did support
an additional few,
focusing mostly on
families and couples.
UX plays a large
role here as well.
Apple's keyboard,
their emoji keyboard,
reinforces this false
binary by only displaying
male and female emoji.
But Google's keyboard
also had problems,
where they may have only
showed one single gender
in the keyboard, but
because some of the designs
were explicitly male
and others were female,
there was this arbitrary
mishmash of genders.
So how did we address
this poor implementation?
The visual design
played a big role.
Some emojis simply
required a change
in hairstyle or clothing color.
Others required more refinements
like accessories, props,
and body language.
And others really forced us
to look each other in the eye
and think deeply about gender.
Now many have argued that
these emojis representations
don't offer us much visually.
However, we can't avoid gender
anymore than culture can.
And you have to stare
at it really in the face
to understand it.
And so that's what
we're trying to do.
We're trying to find what
are the signifiers that
make something feel
either male or female
or both male and female?
Gender, after all,
it's a construct.
So when exploring
signifiers that
have potential to
communicate this ambiguity,
it's important to remember
that gender lives dynamically
on a spectrum.
And there's no single
visual design solution
and giving un-gendered emojis
a gender inclusive appearance
really isn't trivial.
Gender inclusive
designs are intended
to represent a
person of any gender.
You could argue that a
gender inclusive design works
if the gender
inclusive artwork is
truly ambiguous to the viewer.
But, due to each
individual's own perception
of ascribing gender,
it's possible some people
look at the existing
male emoji designs
and see a woman with short hair.
Or look at the
female emoji design
and see a man with long hair.
So where does that leave us?
Are there signifiers
that can provide clues
which don't rely on the binary?
Like haircut or clothing
or color or body language
or other facial features?
What level of product detail
is too much or not enough?
Because emojis really
demand an instant read.
Contextual clues do
influence perception.
Professions associated with
one gender more than the other
can impact your perception.
But what about if you're dead?
What's your gender if
you're a part of the undead?
And that's kind of the point.
Context is king with emoji.
After all, emoji with
contextual elements
are most effective in
clarifying our meaning, provided
there isn't something
that's contradicting it
or conflicting it.
That isn't present.
The least misconstrued
smiley motives
are frequently embellished with
popular interpretation aides,
such as hearts or
tears or dominant
upturned or down-turned mouths.
So while, yes,
hair is one factor,
other things like
clothing and accessories
can inform perception.
Given how fluid and
dynamic language and gender
presentation can be, it's not
inconceivable that regardless
of haircut, shirt color,
accessories, other clues,
gender inclusive emoji
could be repurposed
in some other manner.
Like prince, princess,
emperor, head of state.
And because I work
at Google, I really
wanted to understand how
Google search interprets images
as it relates to gender.
A researcher at Google
had been exploring
what happens when you apply a
makeup classifier to an image,
and which features
change in that image.
So I took the image she
generated and just put them
through Google image
search results.
So you see this image
of a prototypical-- what
you might call a man,
right, Google image
sent back possible
related search gentlemen.
I was like, OK, Google
image search gets it.
They get that this is
a picture of a man.
So ran the next image through,
and it changed it to boy.
Super interesting.
OK, so what happens when we
run the next image through?
It shot back boy again.
OK, no change there.
Got all excited.
Well, the fourth image
also reads back boy.
Maybe this experiment
will get me nowhere.
But I ran the fifth one
through, and it changed to girl.
And the next one
also became girl.
The last one returned
models with bleached brows,
so we're getting
somewhere interesting,
As it relates to what the
makeup classifier is changing.
But also that there is the
spectrum of interpretation,
not just in gender,
but also in age.
So tackling the first phase
of using gender inclusive
designs for code points
which do not specify gender
is pretty clear.
Support existing code points
that do not have gender.
So this was Google's
emoji font set in 2018.
And here it is in 2019,
fully compliant to Unicode
guidelines.
So now, when you text
someone, "I feel so relaxed",
you don't have to worry.
You can feel relaxed.
When we launched
these, the reception
was enormously positive.
People finally
feeling like they felt
like they didn't have to choose
between two genders anytime
they just wanted to
simply express some joy.
Most of the gender
inclusive emoji
rolled out in 2019,
although some rolled out
in 2020 as well.
And we're seeing
much wider adoption.
There's been rapid development,
as major vendors such as Apple
roll out their designs,
and Twitter as well.
The experience around
selecting these emojis
seems to be a work in progress.
Apple has chosen to simply
add the third option
alongside male and
female designs.
Google has opted for one
design to be the default,
asking people to opt
into their gender.
This also makes
it really so much
easier to just browse your
keyboard for the right emoji,
because there's less redundancy.
But now comes the hard part.
What to do with the 12
explicitly gendered emoji?
OK, man in tuxedo.
This is fairly simple.
We make it a person in tuxedo.
We add support for a woman
in tuxedo and man in tuxedo.
Now we have James Bond,
Jesse Bond, James Bond.
That same logic can apply to
woman, person, and man in veil.
But what do about Mrs.
Claus and Santa Claus?
We get Mix Claus.
Now I know what you're thinking.
There's no such
thing as Mix Claus,
but there's also no such
thing as Santa Claus.
Now, the breastfeeding emoji
did stump the group a bit.
Do we simply change the existing
design for this code point,
to remove it from the
explicitly gendered list?
And then we can, if so desired,
add additional sequences
for men and women?
Well the general consensus
was that people did not
feel comfortable changing
the woman breastfeeding emoji
to be more inclusive.
And since we don't
use sex signifiers
to denote gender
representation in our designs,
we're really unable to settle
on a reasonable fallback,
and opted instead to create
an entirely new emoji.
Man, woman, and
person feeding baby.
The logic being simply that
since the only emoji that
depicts anyone one with
childcare was breastfeeding,
there just really weren't
any emoji that really
expressed nurturing your child.
In my opinion,
though, parenthood
is already representable with
a tornado and a pile of poop.
And, people, one
of the things I do
try to think about is how
this emoji is being used,
and how it will be used.
And so finally, we do have an
appropriate Father's Day emoji.
Other emoji, like
bearded person,
are clearly designed in a
way that's more masculine.
Moving forward, bearded
person will be shown
in a more inclusive manner.
But what to do about bearded
woman and bearded man?
Beards have long been
indiscriminate of gender
throughout history,
and truth be told,
this isn't really about women
with beards or men with beards.
It's more of a question of
do people with long hair
have beards?
And the answer is yes.
Right?
When you watch
Eurovision, there's
a great number of men
and women with long hair
and beards in the world.
And many that are very
cultural relevant.
Which is why these
resolutions can be complex.
We can't simply change the
design of existing emoji
anytime culture changes.
So we have to anticipate,
not just where we are now,
but where we will be going.
The flamenco dancer.
She's iconic.
She's really become something
emblematic of something
so much more than
simply dancing.
But if you really go back
and think about iconography,
you can look at the
man bathroom symbol.
Why does this mean man
and not just person?
Because someone added a skirt
to create a woman design.
Why would they do that?
Because they've
effectively done is
reinforced that,
what would have been
a perfectly acceptable
default gender inclusive
symbol for person, is now a man.
Which reinforces our
man-centered society.
I don't know what
the blobs were.
They were just good
little friends.
This was the original
dancer emoji in 2013.
It wasn't a woman.
It wasn't a man.
It wasn't a child.
It wasn't an animal.
It was just a dancer.
And 2015, phones get fancier.
Details get added.
And now, we have these
fairly sexualized dancers,
and in their
specificity and detail,
they've alienated a great
deal of other kinds of dance.
What about African dance?
Polynesian dancing?
Or boogie woogie?
And 2019, we see something
that is really fun.
But when you're thinking
about encoding emoji
and putting broad concepts that
cover the concept of dancing,
not specifically
flamenco dancing,
paying attention to those
details is really important.
But I digress.
What do we do?
What do we do about woman
flamenco dancer and man disco
dancer?
We don't have
something that just
conveys the concept of dancing.
We are not going to change
the existing code points.
This is not a path forward,
we want to move forward with.
So what if we added
a third type of dance
for the gender inclusive?
This-- be provocative.
Here's a break dancer.
But it seems appealing.
But is it future proof?
Will we still be happy with this
gender inclusive type of dance
five years from now, two years
from now, 10 years from now?
Will this create more problems
in the future or less?
In my mind, if we get gender
inclusive break dancing emoji,
why don't we have it for for
women and for men as well?
So another possibility
is to just simply design
male and person
counterpoints points
to the flamenco dancer and
women and gender inclusive
counterpoints to
the disco dancer.
But do we really need
this many flamenco dancers
on our keyboard and
this mini disco dancers?
Probably not.
Another emoji that
is being discussed
is the pregnant woman emoji.
One sex doesn't really dictate
the capacity to care for--
in the home or at
work, or in the market.
So if you look towards
sex equality law, that
aims to combat harmful
sex stereotypes,
it has a lot of parallels with
how we're un-sexing pregnancy
and how it could do the
same for parenthood.
So let's take a
look at how we've
un-sexed the pregnancy emoji.
The British Medical
Association's guidance
on inclusive language
advises people
to use the term
"pregnant people",
instead of a stereotype
term "pregnant women".
Why?
Because though a large
majority of people
who have been pregnant
or have given birth,
identify as women there are
intersex men and trans-men who
may get pregnant.
So we've decided,
instead of changing
the existent
pregnant women emoji,
to simply add a swollen
belly to a person
design and a swollen
belly to a man design.
That is very similar
to what we did
with the bride and the groom.
However, much like
the flamenco dancer--
and much like the
flamenco dancer,
there was a strong desire not
to correct the legacy decision
to double down on
pregnant women.
But now, we finally have that
emoji for when you're hungry.
You have eaten that burrito.
What emojis can you use to
employ about how full you are?
Sure, a burrito
and a tongue emoji.
But that's not really--
that face looks more
like "I'm hungry",
not that I ate too much.
But now, with swollen
belly, you finally
have the perfect
emoji for lunchtime.
Language emerges
from human minds
interacting with each other.
It's visible in the
unstoppable change
we see through slang and
jargon and the formation
of new languages, like texting.
And what I love
about this program
is that it forces me to
zoom out of my tiny world
and realize that we're in
the middle of the story.
We're not at the beginning,
and we're not at the end.
As Google and others roll out
more ambiguous and inclusive
designs for code points
that don't specify gender,
a significant
acknowledgment is happening.
Our emoji are moving
away from heterosexuals
as their default to here are
two people, here is a family.
The beautiful thing about
language is how it evolves.
Words don't any stand
still like formal writing.
It's like water.
It's fluid.
And Unicode's waters are still,
but they are very, very deep.
So I just want to say
thank you for watching.
I've really enjoyed exploring
this with all of you,
and have a great day.